we're standing right now and part of the
Vikings exhibit which is super cool I
want to know - have you had a chance to
walk around carryout now that the
public's out
I want to geek out and walk around in
private now or the public's out I am I
was lucky enough to see this exhibition
in London when it's where it started
nearly a year and a half ago I think so
I've already seen the exhibit but yeah
I've never never had the chance to walk
around it like I'm on my own or private
museum which I might start getting out
it's pretty cool I find a lot of history
fans are history buffs what do people
say when they recognize you on the
street these days from Vikings what are
the things they're telling you are they
ever saying that was inaccurate you know
what I mean because I find a lot of
people they look for those accuracies
which you're sure does like them amazing
job it's it's it's that's interesting
question because sometimes you meet
people that are really into history and
actually I think generally they're just
really happy that they've got a show
that represents Vikings in some way or
another I mean and until to the extent
that that we do we try and be a starkly
accurate as possible as a drama series
can be so generally that you know that's
a nice feeling you tend to get people
just you know thankful that there is a
show about Vikings that that is
discursive on TV in the first place but
then you get another type of fan when it
comes to my character that sometimes and
now and again usually want to have my
beard I'm walking down the street and
then we'll you're here is you know you
suddenly think you gonna get an axe on
the back of the you know in the back of
the head have you gotten used tonight
after because I mean your star is just
constantly rising and I it feels weird
you say allowed to do so right there but
I mean people freak out when they see
somebody on screen
or really like have you gotten used to
that fame and recognition I think you
can never get used to it really um but
it's a compliment I mean uh you know I
had never been in a situation where I
felt unsafe for and you're scared it's
generally just warmth and yeah we go to
comic-con every year and it's I not
understand actors who don't like
comic-con I mean I'm a big nerd myself
but when I get there
you can you can say anything anything
you want you know and people scream back
at you and yeah and it's kind of like
you've got your own clan and it's great
you know I can never really judge
anybody no matter how you know
over-the-top they get within the show
because it actually it's just the
biggest compliment you can ever want to
receive so season five is flip tattoo
we're gonna move on to season 5b I know
you can't spill a lot of details to us
but what can you tell fans that they can
expect coming up in the rest of the
season well I always say that Rollo is
like a volcano so when he does erupt
you know it's devastating and you always
have to expect the unexpected with Robin
because whenever you leave him whenever
he comes back he's always either learned
from his mistakes or or you know it's
what he does when he gets back up and
this is another there's another example
of this he's coming back on that boat
he's learned some things when he's been
in France and he's coming back with with
an agenda and it's never what you expect
it to be he has some unfinished business
with lagertha with Bjorn and definitely
some unfinished business with Ivor the
bonus I think that kid needs to be taken
down a peg or two and he hasn't met his
match yet and he might just have done
with Rollo
uncle Rollo again talking about being an
actor there's so many great things about
being an actor but another scary part is
not knowing maybe what's coming up for a
character like when you get a new script
are you like okay is this the one
I'm done after this look don't you cost
and we kind of worrying about being
killed off of something or a show ending
I do know in Vikings I was I mean I I
always knew where Rollo was going to end
up in history that the historical Rollo
was always going to be the Duke of
Normandy he's the great-great-great
grandfather of William the Conqueror but
in a drama show you never know of you're
playing that Rollo you could just be
playing a Viking called Rollo who seems
very similar because in in this day and
age when producers get involved or when
ratings get involved if you don't sing
with the audience then you can be gone
in the next episode so I was always
reading the last paces to kick off I was
still alive because he's getting up to
no good he's you know he's traitor and
he's you know he's a letch at times and
and you're like God then everyone's
gonna want to keep him around but you
know time told that he was that Rollo
I'm in history and we had a character in
a season one called life and his his his
father was called Eric and we thought
for a while he might be life Eric's son
but he died in episode 8
so yeah you never know if you're safe
and I'm hopefully there will be another
life that will come into the show and he
really will be life erickson and
discover America 500 years before
Christopher Columbus why do you think
fans are so into this show I know it's
hard to guess like you said people are
into different things there's nerds out
there that like certain things but why
don't like this show is massive there's
no doubt about it like people love IX my
own personal opinion about why I think
Vikings is so popular is I think you
can't pigeonhole it it's an historical
drama but usually in that genre we
compare period dramas to things like
Downton Abbey and Pride and Prejudice
but it's because of the type of people
the Vikings were and the Norseman were
the gods and monsters and the pagan
religion it almost seems fantastical so
therefore the people that like Game of
Thrones and the fantasy shows like Lord
of the Rings there's something for them
as well yeah and all they also they were
adventurous and there's battles and
those adventure and intrigue and it just
it seems to tick every single box for
somebody so you can get something out of
it and that's not just credit for our
show it's just credit for who the
Vikings worth